hey everybody time once again for one of
our updates it's Tuesday I put the
regular episode up earlier today so
hopefully everybody's enjoying that cuz
that's like almost three and a half
hours long that turned out yes and we
were super towards it's true Friday
Saturday Saturday yeah yeah today is
actual Tuesday so we're actually doing
this on the afternoon of the same day
that I'm putting it up so uh what's our
update today you actually went to the
grocery store today yeah what's a
grocery store which one did you go to
we do Publix okay what's gonna go to
Walmart Walmart but then started
thinking about it I was like man if any
place is gonna be infected it's gonna be
[ __ ] Walmart well and I don't even
like to go to Walmart at the best of
times had to get cat food mostly cat
food no mohini's needed food anyway I
was there my observations were is that
there's food in there yeah there's food
if you were hungry you can get anything
you could get somebody
there's the delis are [ __ ] rolling
you know they're cooking chickens and
[ __ ] lots of fresh food so there's
definitely not a supply problem now some
of the shelves were bare yeah but it was
like the canned goods I noticed that
when we were there like several days ago
I was stockpiling yeah I was like pretty
much all that I noticed was gone and we
went to Publix it was probably the same
one that you went to today and this was
probably like maybe five days ago six
days ago something like that yeah the
only thing I noticed being like really
completely almost gone was pasta like
pasta canned foods like there were a lot
of soups were gone try beans peas and
stuff like that shelf-stable stuff that
was whoa yeah but other than that um
there was stuff everywhere like a you
know the meat cases were still full I
know that some people don't can't food
everywhere yeah I know some people have
said that they were having trouble
getting fresh meat but there's no favor
really no they must have got a new
shipment then well I have to check out
counter I was like they're hitting
certain sections in there just
yeah and I know that's what I know yeah
like all the I went to go find some
orange juice right yeah all of the
Publix orange juice which is like three
hundred three dollars and fifty cents a
gallon all that was gone
yeah but they had the $7 a gallon
[ __ ] drop again the Tropicana I was I
was like man I'm not gonna pay that
yeah so I went and I just said and so I
went over the input to the International
section and I got the koi is 25 now they
didn't have any orange but they had
mango and [ __ ] pineapple and so and I
like pineapple juice and we still we
have apple juice that we got it's a long
time ago yeah I drink that's the nice
thing about drinking vodka is you can
pretty much mix anything with it so it's
not like there's no food they're hidden
sir-sir things and that's what people
are saying and Publix in particular
they're kind of known for you know their
deli their bakery uh they have like a
shit-ton they have like a whole big case
of like pre-prepared
things were it's like they just have it
all like already portioned out like
shish kebabs or whatever and you just
throw it in the oven
um and I feel like last time I was there
pretty much all of that stuff was still
there yeah anything that was like an MRE
is gone
yes do two more meals that yeah they're
OK for you guys if you don't know I
might tell you I came up on MREs being
in the Army and everything the only
thing really special about the MRE is
the packaging instead of in a can
instead of it being in a can it's in
it's in a heavy foil package a wrapper
that's really the only thing special
about those and in that MRE meal is
everything you need including like
toilet paper people don't think about
that and things like mint chewing gum
because we didn't use toothpaste yeah
that you couldn't issue you toothpaste
but they can issue your gum the can't
clean your teeth off we brought our own
toothpaste the toothpaste would never
survive inside of a damn MRE for ten
years or whatever the the company that
makes those MREs got into a bidding war
with digi more and Duty more lost but
they have an MRE it's it's a dental more
little food thing comes in a tray it's
got me yeah you buy fur like your work
lunch arriver cuz I bought a couple of
minutes 11 or whatever when I was
desperate for food yeah that's basically
an MRE main meal
the person isn't very big but you know I
use them like MREs you know like I keep
them in packs and [ __ ] bug out bags
and so if you ever have to run you just
grab a package yeah we have a vacuum
sealer so here I actually has like a
whole bunch of yeah stuff within it you
have ones that have like everything in
it right that have even have like coffee
creamer yeah granola bars it's just like
you know it's one package like for
everything you're gonna need that day
you know yeah well you do that yeah I
kind of like but then I broke them down
because they're easier to store yeah but
what I you know because I have my own
vacuum packer and you can get those off
eBay for cheap and then the bags you
know I mean it's it's like a big roll of
plastic but the bag isn't sealed you can
make any size bag you want you could
last I used to have one of those that my
uh I got everything in there man got
dried milk vacuum packed I got dried
eggs dried omelet stuff yeah
vacuum pack all that [ __ ] man and if
there's no air and it'll last forever
yeah you can just get off that like
[ __ ] tent without all the damn
[ __ ] cheese cracker stuff you cut a
you cut a slot in the bag and then
rewrap it and vacuum pack the whole
thing suck all the air even out of the
original package yeah like if you're
gonna pack it a vacuum pack something
that's already in a package make a hole
in that package so the vacuum will go
with that air come so that air come
because they put a little bit of air in
there yes you know that's telecaster not
too long oh you can vacuum pack ramen
you can even though it's not real
nutritional it's just it's a lot of
calories though you know at that time I
was also a whole cans of spam yeah so
you just take it if you take a whole can
of spam and dice it up put it in the
damn pasta you can might be feed to
people maybe throw yeah easily maybe
three people and it's a lot of calories
that's like 700 calories apiece yeah if
it's two people which is like half half
or a third so but anyway the stuff like
the dental more ready meals we're gone
yeah other people were hip to that so
they got there they're making bug out
bags well like I said people buy those
for work generally and they'll buy like
a whole bunch of em at once and just
take one for lunch every day
and they they know they last a long time
because sometimes you can take like a
[ __ ] ton of them to work and like leave
them in your desk or your cabinet or
whatever so little plastic tray looks
like something you get on an Airlines
and you pull the top of it off of it you
know I mean it's got a plastic top yeah
it you can eat it frozen it doesn't have
to be like one of the best ones that was
good frozen I learned in Korea was that
damn tuna and noodles MRE I would see
that witness sounds terrible but the
tuna noodles and ham slice it's a big
old block of ham when that was frozen it
was all right well I like my chicken
chewing it and be all crispy it's like
something Eskimos it eat yeah frozen
pizza like I said some stuff that you
can eat cold like tuna people eat like
tuna salad like yeah that cold and stuff
and I eat cold ham sandwiches it'd be
like cold noodle tuna noodle salad yeah
like that it was pretty good yeah and
people eat macaroni salad and that's
cold so yeah but I didn't really sense
any kind of panic out there they look
normal
the traffic was a little tame but they
were still out there behind stuff that's
what I thought like when I went to the
UM you know when I went to the post
office which I guess was what was that
last Friday it's Tuesday today um I
didn't really notice any different it's
like other than the traffic being
lighter for a weekday that was about it
it's like there were still people I know
people aren't really supposed to be
walking around but I know like people
still have to go to work and stuff yeah
this is crazy and get some crazy
comments in the damn comments section
that reference another thing don't there
are people profiting off of in different
ways profiting off of panning for this
this is not as deadly as people want you
to believe it is it's the average age of
a person is dying is in their 80s and
they have other complications on top of
it these people we're gonna die anyway
if you're in your 80s you're on borrowed
time you just are just be honest you
know their lifespans measured maybe in
months for years they were the people
that even without that virus a lot of
them didn't have long ago anyway
some of these people that are dying
while they're in the hospital some of
them people would have died you know
with
best medical care anyway there was
nothing you really do you know there are
some people that are weak and they're
just Tigran everyday people die it's a
normal part of life yeah well like I
said I feel like they may have been
dying anyway
well the [ __ ] sick and it pushes them
over but this is what I'm trying to say
collapsing an entire civilization to try
to save a small percentage of the people
1% 2% 3% it doesn't make any goddamn
sense you know I mean you don't collapse
your own civilization just to just to
save you know I mean a small percentage
of the people actually you don't
collapse a civilization even if if it
kills 99% of them and if 1% survive you
do that because from that 1% you can
grow another population it's not you
know it's not extinction you know so
eventually what they're gonna do is
they're gonna say we need the economy
more than we need these people because
if the economy goes civilization will
collapse and then just millions and
millions of people will die because
without an economy without modern
technology you will not be able to
support the population that you have
industry will go away and then the
population level will have to fit a
pre-industrial society that's a fraction
of what we have now so you're talking
about billions of people dying yeah well
I mean like I said I I feel like even
now and yet it's hard to say like in our
area because we're kind of in a suburban
you know slightly upper-middle class
area um I haven't really seen that much
weird around here it's just like
everything seems fairly you know other
than the traffic like I go out you know
in the morning like to exercise and
stuff and that's just normal it's like
there's people jogging there's people
walking their dogs there's like people
doing regular [ __ ] it's just you know
it's just kind of weird that and you you
know you go to Publix and then like the
whole shelf of pasta is gone and that's
a little weird but other than that it's
like everything looks pretty copacetic
people I know that other cities are not
the same though I mean reality's gonna
come crash
down on these people people got to eat
they need power they need food they need
they need water you can't just sit at
home the civilization will fall [ __ ]
apart these people will die eventually
so what they're gonna do is they're
gonna wait and they're gonna wait a
couple more days probably and see where
the ineffective people are how many of
them there are they're gonna quarantine
those areas and then they're gonna
[ __ ] tell everybody to get back to
work they just go back and do normal yes
it to go back and get to work because
it's not worth it to [ __ ] destroy
your civilization and kill billions of
people just to save some old people that
sounds cruel but that's reality
well you can't like leave a whole bunch
of working-age people at home just me
all the children in the future
generations you enjoy their future it's
a good analogy would be a dam the
Titanic you have people in a lifeboat 50
people in the lifeboat there's hundreds
of people in the water trying to get in
that damn lifeboat if they get in that
lifeboat they'll all die one of those
people those lifeboats do the actual
were hitting people with damn oars you
know no then once we're trying to get in
cuz it capsized the lifeboat they don't
die so you know at least some people
would live yeah you know and that's what
that's the situation we're in we're not
even talking about those odds we're
talking about somewhere between 1 and 3
percent I bet you well I guess orb those
caves are the casualties yeah I see
nothing I think what's dangerous like I
said as people I'm not saying don't take
it seriously because you should it's
like yes you know don't try not to get
infected and try not to pass it other
people if you have in a bla bla bla like
do all that kind of stuff but also you
know don't flip out and buy up
everything so other people can't have it
don't know the system's working that I
mean it's like you know there's places
to get food I don't no matter where you
live it's like I don't know some people
like that live another place that you
know may think maybe their supply lines
aren't as good or whatever but and look
but I think MoDOT McDonald's was open um
yeah well fast food places I've heard
are you doing really well I think it was
open because you can still do most now a
lot of restaurants are still open but
they've shifted to delivery only like
you can't go in there you can just like
call them and pick stuff up or they'll
the problem is Del's or - but I have to
get back to work so they can make money
to buy the food and they need to do
[ __ ] do their rent and all that money
that they that they need to survive
fuels the economy that's what I mean
that seems more what I'm worried yeah
I'm worried about right you know um you
know even though our you know we do a
YouTube show like I write books and
stuff too but it's like I have a thing
where you know my graphic design work
has already kind of gone down a lot
because most of the graphic design work
that I do is for bands like for people's
shows like for nightclubs and stuff like
that and all that shit's closed so no
one's commissioning anything right which
kind of sucks and it's a big cycle so
you know yes not just entertainment food
its shelter fuel [ __ ] heavy industry
yeah I mean like are they buying cars
are they building cars you know salka
are they building houses right now and
then the people that build the houses
are they able to feed their kids they
just they can't stay this for long I
predict within a couple of days that we
try to figure out where the infected are
and they're kind of quarantine those
areas and then they're just gonna let
ride say everybody else's yeah back to
work because they can just be careful
yeah because it's just like wartime some
guys are gonna die
but most people will live yeah just like
that you can't sacrifice everyone just
for just for a few people that are gonna
die yeah the human race has to continue
the civilization has to continue they
just you can't be
we're defeated and just be a puss and
stay at home just can't it's not gonna
happen
yeah they're gonna tell everybody get
back to work they tried to hand out
checks the other day they [ __ ] that up
and so what does that tell you they
gotta go back to work well yeah because
the Republicans and Democrats are just
gonna fight you can't trust them for
your own survival you gotta cover your
own ass so if he asked me I think
Trump's gonna say okay everybody back to
work and like people got died but better
than a civilization collapsing is a bit
[ __ ] collapses and nobody's in charge
then that means I'm in charge yeah guys
don't want that no you really don't you
know straight Mad Max on matter of
[ __ ] days when I'm in charge it's
gonna be very different
yes um so not alone there's millions of
me millions and millions and millions
and
he's out there all ex-military guys and
to take babe lottie's ex-military guys
don't like you hate to say it but they
just see you as weak you know they were
like he doesn't deserve that woman he
doesn't deserve that food he doesn't
just goes back to [ __ ] caveman days
especially when there's whole [ __ ]
private armies I've been running around
and that's what would happen that's what
happen when Rome fell it was nothing but
just the room the remains of the Roman
army ran around on the end of the
becoming war lords and knights that
[ __ ] founded the dem you know
medieval era that's that would just
happen again humans haven't changed yeah
not really no uh more hairless apes
we're monkeys what I um what I was gonna
ask you was we got a new patron named
hobo nasty yeah and he asked a question
on patreon and usually I usually monitor
the patreon account and you know so so I
thought you could answer it on the show
okay so he asked you is the National
Guard a bad thing and what is it we need
to expect from them well I guess he's
talking about some areas must have
activated the National Guard probably
like emergency disaster relief
it's just pedestrian regular [ __ ]
usually what they're do that in
hurricanes they do it all the time it
doesn't there's this [ __ ] fantasy
that there could be like a military
takeover okay
yeah or that the military can [ __ ]
stop in and can stop in and stop a civil
war that's just fantasy all of the
entire active-duty military could not
even really maintain security inside of
Iraq or Afghanistan these are little
bitty countries and they were mostly
unarmed America's armed to the teeth as
Jen the geography is huge
you just can't secure it and then all
your police are at a bare minimum
security level more like a thickening
but they they can investigate crimes
they can write tickets they can give the
illusion that they're security but
there's just not enough cops even [ __ ]
went south real fast no army could stop
it no police force
stop it be just like a trainer so beyond
you that's why people are buying all
those guns but daily beyond you to
secure your family and yourself and your
neighborhood but that's not unusual
mostly there's a lot of countries that
are like that Afghanistan was like that
yeah I was gonna say it's tribal you
know what's really weird is that laughs
last night when I was sitting around
like I was just watching Netflix or
whatever and the power went out for a
second yeah we were both like oh we were
like okay but then it came right back on
and then we were like looking down trees
like what the [ __ ] it's weird because
like a few minutes before that I heard a
really really bad like a car screeching
like down the the [ __ ] road outside
and I was kind of like I didn't hear a
crash but I was like did it crash into a
transformer like way down the road or
something like that because for a second
we looked out the back door and thought
that other people in the neighborhood
were out - but then we looked further
and it wasn't but it's just it came back
on and we were just like we're like
weirded out for a second because it
wasn't like storming or anything like
that
it's like power goes out when it storms
all the time but yeah it's just it was
really strange we're like oh [ __ ] that's
all we need like in the middle of this
[ __ ] it's like not having power either
like I said we've done we've done that
with hurricanes and it's super not fun
to repeat that the other day Trump was
in that dam talking to the median he
says we have to we should he said the
cure to this might be worse than the
actual disease we need to get people
back to work to prevent deaths and the
newspaper people what debt what deaths
you're talking about Trump kind of
talked his way out of it he says well
you know be suicides and people not
being to pay their bills that's not what
he meant though what he meant was is
that the longer there isn't kind of like
an active presence of control or the
longer it seems like shits out of
control the greater risk of what they
would call civil unrest could come about
you doubt I mean it'd be like well
they're not in charge so that means
we're in charge so you'd have possibly
riots that could turn into revolutions
or movements to try to break away from
the United States or to create a second
version of the United States in the same
way that had happened in the Soviet
Union
there were all the breakaway republics
Americans are kind of brainwashed into
thinking that that's not possible here
because their upbringing tells them that
that they're special in that America is
a special country
oh it's special all right no it could
have a here too there's a lot of people
that have political disagreements with
everybody else they don't want to be in
the same country you do and all they'd
have to do is go run around and be like
a damn get on social media and start
making it a cool thing to go run around
shoot the damn Transformers and it
wouldn't take long before the power grid
would be down and the stockpile of all
the Transformers isn't enough to replace
them all takes them a long time to make
them and if they were to actually get
that done which probably wouldn't take
that many people a couple hundred guys
may be spread out in key locations
probably taking about 12 hours to do it
if they had it pre-planned it's like it
was a group of guys we're talking about
it they could get it done pretty quick
and chances all the power would never
come back on as soon as the power's out
in those major cities three days later
they're killing each other over food
just like in Katrina and they would
never be able restore order it wouldn't
be there wouldn't be enough power to run
the system to build the Transformers you
need to replace them and then as soon as
you put one in there those same guys
[ __ ] shoot them out again when
there's a wielders away all warfare is
basically a battle of wills whoever has
the most will wins and the United States
has never been able to win against just
guys with guns Vietnam was like that
Afghanistan was like that Iraq was like
that after the fall Saddam
you know I mix infantry I'm telling the
ultimate weapon is a man with a rifle
who's willing to die you just can't beat
them especially if there's a bunch of
them jets are no good against them tanks
are no good against them so these people
have to get back to work that's what I'm
saying or bad [ __ ] like that will
eventually become an option it'll be
seen as a weakness and I'm saying uh-huh
that's a lot of people don't want to
believe that but just it's just happened
so many times you throughout history it
may be in slightly different ways but
that's the pattern
no there's nothing special you know if
there isn't a clear-cut
government and that means somebody else
is gonna step up you know what I mean
yeah and man you look at politics in the
United States it's not clear that there
is a government if you ask me there's no
clear leadership one way or the other
but like I said it's you know I I just
don't think it's gonna get to that point
then I'm gonna let it get to that point
well yeah I don't think it's gonna get
to that point I think they're gonna get
them doctors they're gonna get them back
together I'll go back to and and I feel
like you know Americans are just kind of
like yeah we go through a lot of bad
[ __ ] and everything like that but after
a while it just kind of goes back to
normal or it's like it's slightly
different normal and everyone's just
kind of like okay well this is gonna be
that's just how we [ __ ] deal with it
now yeah this is acceleration pretty
resilient this is acceleration ISM it is
accelerated everything like diamond
diamond comics distribution went out of
business state which means that the
comic book industry is now gone because
Marvel needs it and Marvel was teetering
and DC needs not the movies but the
comic books and the reason why Diamond
closed and they they handled all the
distribution I was talking to my friend
about it last night we used white
diamond clothes because too many comic
book shops closed so they couldn't keep
afloat and then when this hit they
realized that the comic books that were
teetering the comic book stores that
were teetering or the thing in the past
so there's no more comic book industry
that's that's on its way up well I hope
that book industry is still okay because
that's kind of my [ __ ] everything is
connected with everything else
alright the comic book industry now
can't can't do print and it can't
deliver print and it's not
technologically where it's not
economically viable so they're gonna be
online but nobody knows if a four dollar
online comic book is a viable product I
don't think it is I think a four dollar
comic book is [ __ ] crazy and when I
was a kid they were [ __ ] with 55
cents when they got it to a dollar
I remember kids going what the [ __ ] a
dollar that was a long time ago has a
long time ago
but now they're $4 so what kid can spend
$4 per day
comic book and they don't seem to be
into that [ __ ] anyway they seem to be in
the video games well like I said comic
books are not really the same thing as
they used to be the old days now they're
like actual books with like
illustrations not the ones are talking
about
I saw they're just like the old comic
books we have yeah they're thin even so
I don't think 4 bucks is that much for
that I mean considering Welkin yeah but
if you look if you were into it you
would that's like not even as much as a
drink at Starbucks well they wouldn't
sell no we're sailin well you know
that's why they're closed and they
weren't saying I'm just saying it's not
that expensive like in the grand scheme
of things and if they if they didn't
sell in print I don't think they'd sell
in online well I don't know I I don't I
don't know what the what the market is
like for like a book comic books cuz I
know a lot of people do those um so I
you know for a while like ebooks were
out selling print books now I kind of
feel like it's even you know what I mean
well they were seeing that the writing
was [ __ ] in the Marvel once I mean they
said the DC ones were a little bit
better but they're most of the money was
going to these kind of like custom jobs
that were they were started up a bunch
of money on Kickstarter to get him
written like The Expendables once was
really good stiff as best as Stallone
was involved in that and I think just
didn't matter of like a day they they
were able to raise like a hundred fifty
thousand well if you're doing like a
whole like if you want to do like a
whole series of that probably
Kickstarter is your best no I don't know
it was a series it was a big book yeah
there's something like graphic novel
because those take a really long time
yeah yeah I mean you know small
Expendables go to hell yeah and
evidently they do they go to hell like
well I just got a thing from I got an
email from ACX today who do my
audiobooks and they're apparently for
the next few months they're like upping
the royalties 5% because they're worried
about you know creators not getting
enough money and stuff so they're
actually given the creators a little bit
more royalties oh the next three months
I think I don't know if I answered the
guy's questions well okay they're
probably called them out for like
emergency disaster relief to hand out
medical stuff or to give medical
treatment to people to make sure maybe
like riots don't break out the chances
are you know when it's NASA
guard it's pretty damn kind of
lightweight if you ask me well I think
it's just like extra help I fail yeah
yeah kind of they're kind of like
substitute cops but I think people have
a tendency to kind of like other eyes
soldiers as if they're another they're
just American dudes you know and worst
case
worst case scenario a lot of people
imagine them being becoming like
something out of Star Wars like the
stormtroopers where they're shooting the
civilians and [ __ ] they don't give a
[ __ ] enough about that worst-case
scenario if unit cohesion ever broke
down and they got desperate
they wouldn't attack civilians they just
run back home with their weapons that's
what they did in the Soviet Union well
because they if they all have families
all have family you know so they go back
home with their weapons and their
vehicles and they [ __ ] protect
wherever wherever they considered to be
home and their family yeah and they use
left a lot of times you know like whole
countries that's how they got their
military I think like Georgia started
off with that's really got their
military because it was all the [ __ ]
Soviet Union guys like it running from
their army and they ran there with tanks
and vehicles and everything yeah yeah
but I think Georgia is now part of the
Soviet Union again no it is it it's not
part of Russia anymore I think it's
still independent in it I don't remember
yeah I know it went back and forth but I
don't know yeah yeah for a while there
hell army was basically stolen Russian
stuff wasn't really stolen because then
the Soviet Union after that he just took
it yeah hey no one's using this yeah
yeah so all I've been doing today I'd
put this show up obviously been watching
some documentaries about our next topic
for this show which I'm not gonna reveal
what it is the Patriots will know
patrons will know on Sunday and also
last night on Netflix I started watching
everybody had been recommended to me
that whole kind of French horror series
Maryann so I finally started watching
that last night I think I'm three
episodes in I think I just started the
fourth one so I probably will review
that on the matinee show on Sunday among
other things I gotta find some other
stuff to watch - I think shudder added
some new [ __ ] but I'm not sure if it's I
mean it's new to them I don't know if
it's like new movies from this year
I mean so I have to look and see what
happens with that but other than that
you got anything else you want to add
yeah people don't don't worry about it
this isn't gonna be a bad you think I've
just I don't think that virus is not
deadly enough to kill enough of us to
make a difference
yeah it's that's what I mean I'm not
really worried about I think in a couple
days I think in a couple days they're
just gonna say all right everybody back
to work that's maybe not places like New
York and you know I mean we're heavily
populated areas but there's gonna be
places out in the south where this [ __ ]
won't spread yeah there's not enough
inner human contact doing oh man you
need those places to keep the system
running and there's still people working
so well the point to me I mean honestly
around here at least it seems like most
people are work yeah because it seems
like most things are still open yeah
restaurants are still open they're just
doing delivery or just drive through all
the grocery stores are still open yeah
all that like [ __ ] everything still
opens though yeah so you might as well
go back to work if you know if your jobs
open I would think like I said cuz
everybody's gonna need someone I don't
think it's gonna make a bit of goddamn
difference goddamn difference
whoever's gonna die is gonna die no
matter what you do I think probably this
is very funny because like several weeks
ago you were like worried about people I
already had girl I've been listening to
dog you're gonna die I think I already
had it already I think I already had I
think I might already had it but I've
been listening to doctors you know I
mean actually explain how it works and
what the numbers really are it's not
that deadly I mean it's just it's just
not deadly that's trying to tell you
like and they're saying well might be
three percent now it might actually be
like 1/10 of a percent because a lot of
people get it they don't even show any
symptoms that's like I don't know how I
didn't have it boy and no one would know
right yeah there's gonna be extra people
dying but it's gonna be people probably
die anyway yeah so on that cheerful note
we'll end our little daily show for
Tuesday we will talk to you guys again
tomorrow see you later